as the world economic Forum draws to a
close a warning youth protesters telling
the rich and influential gathered here
in Davos that they are running out of
time
this is my third time coming to this
place
a place that I've come to understand
that it is so disconnected from what is
happening on the front lines
of the climate crisis so we ask our
leaders to listen to the science to
listen to those that are being impacted
the most and stop all new investments in
fossil fuels and that is coal oil and
gas power to the people even as the
process continued Outside Inside the
Congress Center politicians insisted
they were listening we are the large
generation of politicians if I can say
that that can address this previous ones
didn't it's not either now or never our
voters want it from us our younger
Generations want it from us if we don't
decide we can't leave it to them but the
head of the International Energy agency
a man who's been inside these meetings
says the protesters of right to worry I
don't see the commitment engagement of
the people that I have seen in the last
few years it in a way it may be
understood because the people have many
various immediate worries but it is the
job of a mind job of yours and others to
remind people that it is not something
that we can forget and put it aside it
is a real issue it is with us it will be
even worse by day
one issue is from Ukraine to the economy
there's so much else going on
in the coming days you'll read lots of
articles about what the mood in Davos
was well let me let you in on a little
secret it's all a bit bogus there is no
single mood in Davos because there's so
much going on whether it's protests on
the Promenade you've got private
meetings in hotel rooms and what's
happening in the summit itself it's that
multiplicity of different talks which is
leaving climate campaigners concerned
that it's sucking the oxygen out of the
issue they want discussed
and so the curtain comes down on another
big conference another chance to shift
the dial campaigners worry that there
are not many chances left Ed Conway Sky
News and Davos